so one thing I try to avoid talking
about for reasons and you'll understand
why in a moment I try to avoid talking
about the Democratic primaries not
because I don't have very strong
opinions on each candidate but because
we have a fascist in the White House and
I think we need to govern ourselves
accordingly and what we love to do more
than anything else because I
participated in it and I understand how
how easy it is to get caught up in the
divides on the left side of the spectrum
now mind you that is a really big range
right that includes and includes
centrist Democrats who are basically
conservative particularly on the
international spectrum centrist
Democrats are further to the right then
are equally to the right as the the
Tories in the UK so when we say the
American Left we really are talking
about a really broad range of people
basically who aren't Republican and that
goes from centrist Democrats all the way
to communist socialist Marxist Leninist
there's a very big range but when we
talk about the the the primaries it
becomes very easy for us to engage in
this inter party intra-party battle
basically for what this party is going
to look like what the Democratic Party
is going to look like and and and
included in that are some people who
have similar politics to us but their
approach to this is burn it all down
burn the entire Democratic Party down
there's nothing we can do with it burn
it all down and let's let's commence
with the revolution more power to you we
have a fascist in the White House right
so when election day comes around govern
yourselves accordingly now all that said
I wanted to make sure that you
understood where I'm coming from all
that said there's a lot of interesting
things happening in this primary and we
haven't even begun the primaries in
earnest Bernie Sanders was here in
Atlanta this weekend he made a couple of
gaffes in in response to the questions
from the audience I was actually there
in person and I like Bernie Sanders I'm
actually a huge Bernie Sanders supporter
generally alike all of his policies I
just just from following him though I
think it's safe to say that Bernie
Sanders in a way is not the
revolutionary he's a politician you know
listening to to his answers to the
questions I you know you could see him
calculating like a politician calculates
to make sure that he doesn't commit over
commit under commit and tries to say the
precise thing I think he's far more a
standard politician than we would like
to believe and I say that as a Bernie
Sanders supporter however he's very
closely tied in my opinion with
Elizabeth Warren who has her policies
like we've coined her policy BAE hashtag
policy BAE because she has plans right
and in a way it's like what Bernie
Sanders has the moral clarity on
Elizabeth Warren is demonstrating that
she can make a plan to implement it and
so she has a plan for that and and so
for me
those are the top two in my personal
running and that's just my personal
opinion like you every single one of you
is gonna have a different opinion and
that's fine I think it's important for
us to be able to talk about the good and
the bad in each of our candidates right
I think the most critical thing for us
in this primary is to not fall back into
the vice of being more interested in
fighting internally than realizing the
fight that we have externally with
conservatives because we are at a
pivotal time in American history
I can't overstate I can't say this
dramatic enough right there's no amount
of hyperbole that I can rap this next
sentence in to convey you the severity
of this of what's going on what Donald
Trump has done already it's going to
take almost a full generation for us to
undo when you think of his some 100 or
more judicial picks throughout the
judiciary the federal judiciary when you
think about his picks on the Supreme
Court particularly Kavanagh when you
think about the the massive sweep of of
policies of passing bills anti-abortion
bills specifically with the purposes
of overturning Roe versus Wade and now
we have a conservative majority on the
bench and it's very possible that could
happen the damage that Donald Trump is
doing in his one term is going to take
us a lifetime I mean an entire
generation if I'm around if I haven't
gone crazy or like you know whatever I
have a full beard of white hairs instead
of the one or two that I have by the
time we're able to undo what Donald
Trump has done unless we get some
Democrats who are strong enough and
radical enough to actually shake this
system up right like can we afford to
wait an entire generation for abortions
to be legal again in this country or do
we need Democrats who are willing to
talk about packing the courts in 2020 so
as we look at the primaries it's
important and I think it's I think it's
meaningful for us to argue it's
meaningful for us to be able to look at
the differences between each of these
candidates and to clearly delineate the
good the bad the ugly and the
indifferent like Joe Biden right while
there he's polling wonderfully in the
he's doing wonderful in the polls you
know he's really doing wonderful in the
polls because of Barack Obama right Joe
Biden has a lot of baggage that he has
to take account for he has to be
accountable he has to explain he has to
be able to tell America and and and he's
actually taking the opposite course
right he's saying that he is not gonna
apologize for anything well that's gonna
be a hard road for Joe Biden and and
that's gonna be a problem mayor Pete
mayor Pete doesn't really have any
accomplishments not many to speak of I
mean I know a lot of prolific I know a
lot of dynamic mayor's across the city
but what Mayor Pete does have really
well and I don't mean this as an insult
is a great team a great PR team a great
team of people who know how to amplify
him into the national conversation you
know so they're they're candidates who
are going to be how do I say this I
don't want to I don't want to be
offensive because I don't want to let
this clip be used as a way of dividing
us but I'll just say like this there's
going to be good and bad each of these
candidates some are going to have more
goods
we're gonna have more bed and that's the
entire purpose of the primaries we have
to fight it out we have to hash it out
but you can't hash it a listen
another thing for a lot of people who
are still Bernier busters you cannot win
this fight outside of the Democratic
Party you're like you need a register
you need a registered vote I mean that
was a big impediment last time a lot of
people had not registered to vote they
were fighting they were online and they
were they were intense about their
participation online but they didn't get
and register by the deadline and if you
believe that that the Democratic
establishment is going to sandbag Bernie
Sanders then you have to vote in numbers
that they can't deny right and and then
even more so right there's an
opportunity there has been opportunities
for people to get involved in these
parties and when I say parties I mean
the local parties and to participate so
that that those type of shenanigans
don't happen in your precinct so it's a
huge battle that we have going on that's
going to continue and rightfully so I'm
not telling anyone to not fight about
the primaries I'm saying have it out you
know be sober about your own candidate
like I'm very sober I like Elizabeth
Warren but I'm better I am very keen to
the idea
knocking to the idea that's not what I
want to say I'm very cognizant of the
reality that she's going to have a hell
of a fight
with Donald Trump winning the general
election because of how easily Donald
Trump attacks her in a way that
previously has almost neutralized her so
I want to see that particular fight and
I have problems with some of her foreign
policy similarly Bernie Sanders he has a
couple of blind spots that he's had for
a long time I won't talk about them now
you can go to my channel and see some of
those videos but there's things that we
have to be realistic about about each
and every one of our candidates and I
think for us to have a fair assessment
we need to be honest about the pros and
cons about our candidates just like
we're honest about the cons of the
people that we don't want to become the
nominee but all that said when it's all
said and done I just have to emphasize
and maybe you maybe we need a daily
reminder
no matter how bad oh I forgot about
Camila like you know all the things that
she is and the things that she's not I
just want to emphasize that we have a
fascist in the White House and
authoritarian who would gladly be a
dictator who ignores the rule of law who
thinks he's above the law who ignores
checks and balances who uses the the
bully pulpit of demagoguery to get his
way
currently in the White House so honestly
is unpopular this statement is no matter
how bad any of these Democrats are there
are 100 percent better than the fascist
is sitting in the White House now my
hope is going to be that it would be
Bernie or Elizabeth Warren or
combination thereof but whoever wins I'm
telling you now I'm throwing on their
t-shirt and I'm going door-to-door
thanks so much for hanging out with me
today David we'll be back and we